[Music]
all right let's do it let's do it man
man [ __ ] gaga yes that is like the
refrain without the audiobook man
Skolnick popping in with just like after
every chapter like man
I mean I thought I knew this story right
and I know a lot of it
right uh there's just so much more there
man so much more man unbelievable
it's all surface man I only had an hour
to talk to people in a podcast yeah I
get the surface version of the the book
goes deep dark into the sewer yeah tells
you everything it's an incredible
accomplishment it's such an unbelievable
document it's gonna inspire and catalyze
a lot of growth and a lot of people man
so first off like congratulations on
getting this thing done
thank you a small thing no sir and
what's amazing about it before we even
get into the content of it is that you
made this decision to self publish this
book yes sir right now it's out like
number two or number three on Amazon of
all books all right all right that just
doesn't happen with a self-published
book and you've been able to do this
without any mainstream media whatsoever
like I did a google search this morning
I wanted to see any hits that you had
like in the last week or in the last day
right you're not on The Today Show
you're not you didn't do any of that
this is all self propelled DIY and to go
from you know that place to the very top
like selling the number of books that
you're selling like right out of the
gate is just insane right there's got to
be a lot of people in publishing looking
at that going what is going on here well
that's been the story of my life I I see
something that's that's quite off quite
not the same and that's what I go for
I've just that this book is exactly who
I am as a person exactly the way I did
this book is Howard um my almost my
entire life as I see what is not the
norm what's impossible with we know what
all the theorists say you shouldn't be
doing this
that's the wrong way to go and I'm like
hmm let me see if I can pull this [ __ ]
off yeah over here maybe second pull
this [ __ ] off was that part of the the
challenge the decision I mean I it seems
to me that the decision is
self-published was generated more by a
desire to really you know own your story
that was that's it 100% it's there was
no driven message with me trying to
prove people wrong or whatever it was a
hundred percent by me wanting to own my
life there's a lot of people I know that
that I speak with right now that have
nice book deals out there and the people
who buy their book we are a publishing
house they can't even talk some of this
stuff you know in like like an speaking
engagements you know I'm like what you
can't even talk your story and some of
these like no like I got to make sure
that they're they're aware of it and I'm
like nah man I want to own a hundred
percent of the suffering I went through
in my life I don't anybody telling me I
gotta you can't say this I would lose my
[ __ ] but you I suffered this this badly
and you you can [ __ ] tell me I can't
say this they're been all kind of
problems with that one so I made sure
that I wanted to own all of can't hurt
me and own all of my own life story so
that's what it really is all about well
you really have ownership not only of
your own story but your ability to tell
it right and you know as as somebody
who's like a member of the ultra
community you know I remember and I
think we talked about this last time you
kind of disappeared for a couple years
there around like I don't know what it
was like 2009-2010 that wasn't 13 you've
had like a website in a blog that would
get updated once in a while and I would
check in and try to see what you were up
to and you just went totally dark ghost
man yeah and I didn't know about the
heart stuff there was something about
like oh there's a hell thing that you're
dealing with right and I thought oh this
guy's just disappeared right but you
were that was the recruiting era right
where you were just on the road telling
her story and putting in the reps right
on how to tell your story so it was the
recruiting error for me when I started
becoming like the the Navy SEALs needed
more blacks in in the SEAL Teams and
that's what we don't understand I like
you know why is it become a recruiter in
the SEAL Teams
I was one of the few black guys you know
and I already done bad water
so I got a little bit you know small bit
of notoriety for doing bad water and so
the Navy SEALs like oh my god you know
like we could use this guy to try to get
the the 1% of the African Americans and
Navy SEALs up to maybe 2% and so I hit
the road start doing that but also hey
I'm not a big guy on social media so I
was actually happy to kind of pull away
from it you know I'm just not big on
that stuff even today I'm just not a big
fan of it man I'm a big introvert I get
a lot of my strength from being
introverted and I'm going out there and
doing what I do is very all this is very
difficult for me man oh yeah it's funny
when you say you're introverted because
you're so good
you know when it comes to sharing your
story and it's so compelling and you
know there's a lot of people out there
like quote their quote unquote like
influencers are like wow like this guy's
got I know what do you have like six
hundred thousand-plus on Instagram yeah
yeah and for somebody who's you're
averse to it you don't like it you hate
it you only post once in a while you
don't really advertise what you're doing
at all but your own this huge following
of people who are super interested in
what you're doing well I think it's
important to do things you don't like
and I am I was very ashamed in my life
story for a long time
IIIi didn't want to go out and tell
anybody [ __ ] about me so that's why I
had to people I you know I create one
david Goggins and one Goggins right and
I didn't want people to know that I had
all these issues but after a while
people start to give you these different
tag lines you know like you're
superhuman you're amazing they start my
[ __ ] don't know anything about me man
I'm this insecure kid I started
realizing there's a lot of people out
here who are going through a lot of
problems that I once tapped into you
know I had a whole bunch of issues
growing up and you know I I felt
compelled to this you know what you got
to start sharing this stuff man cuz
people see where you're at today they
see where you're at today they they see
the man you are they this this hard
rock-hard human being show these people
where you come from right as people as
possible
it's funny when you're reading the
like once you get into the later
chapters like six seven or eight you
know all the way to the end you start to
forget chapters one and two that's right
you start thinking this guy is a
superhuman and then you got to remind
yourself like oh man look where he came
from right I actually do it in the
audiobook in the audiobook well while
Adam is reading we have a moment where
we stop because I like six or seven you
know six seven eight where I start doing
all these crazy feats and start going
way beyond human limits for myself and I
tell people why are you hearing this I
know you guys have already forgotten
about how I came up
don't forget the torture I endured
mentally and physically in my own mind
going through all this [ __ ] so no don't
ever forget that so people forget that
so quickly when they get to that seven
eight nine ten chapters so this is yeah
the we should just mention the audio
book I mean the book is amazing but the
audio book is the next level and part of
that is because you guys kind of broke
the paradigm here you made this somewhat
risky decision to have Adam read most of
the book and we can get into the reasons
behind that which I think are well
considered
but then after each chapter you and Adam
break it down podcast style like
informally where you just freestyle on
write that chapter was all about and
that just brings brings it to life in
like this Technicolor way which makes it
just such a compelling experience well
everything I do I try to do my very best
and now that I'm out here trying to
share this story with people I want to
be so real so [ __ ] authentic to the
point where it was embarrassing to me
and as I was writing some stuff and I
was giving it to Adam and we were going
back and forth and like man I'll talk to
my fiancee do I really want people to
[ __ ] know this about me but that's
the power and that's the strength you
can summon to be that vulnerable because
that's how people are gonna be able to
emotionally connect exactly when they
look at what you've done in bad water
and all the buds and all that kind of
stuff it becomes difficult for people to
relate to that
right when you have the strength and the
fortitude to share those parts of your
life that do embarrass you or provoke
shame and you that's the that's the like
that's the real [ __ ] I had to show
people I was human
you know people didn't think I was human
they thought I came from outer space man
from some spacecraft and [ __ ] and landed
down here and formed Goggins from the
rocks and the soil of the earth not know
how it is man so I said yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna share a secret with you all
well in one of the recaps you tell Adam
writing this book was the hardest thing
you've ever done and as somebody who's
done a lot of hard [ __ ] that was a
surprising thing to hear well looking in
the mirror at yourself because I did a
really good job by creating this guy in
now so I could just go by and just live
by this guy here this Who I am do you
think of it as like this because you
refer to yourself in the third person
all this it's like this character that
you're trying to aspire to be that
distinct from you like you you create
this like division how does that work
it's a big division because I do not
talk to people like I see where I'm at
today but I know where I come from and
it's kind of hard to almost separate
that I'm almost not in a way I'm kissing
my own ass but I'm amazed at what a
human being can actually do so I start
talking myself in the third person it
strictly because I know that I literally
made this human being out of out of just
like a whole bunch of scraps mm-hmm and
I wasn't you know I wasn't a mechanic I
wasn't a carpenter so I don't know how
to do anything you know I wasn't trained
and how to build a human being from
nothing you know like my mom didn't
train me my dad didn't train me life in
the training well life blood trail yeah
life did train me correction and I
started putting this scrap metal
together like I want what's the flux
that happened you know the first shot I
do is all [ __ ] up and after I start
learning more and more and more through
pain and suffering start learning normal
just learning so much about stuff before
I knew it man I've built this beautiful
card I'm like how the [ __ ] did I do that
and I knew hunting it and I know how to
do it because I have all the tools do
all the failure I went through trying to
build this person who's Goggins mm-hmm
yeah and that was something I came
across loud and clear which is it's not
like you develop this toolbox and then
everything worked out
no no there's so many ups and downs and
highs and lows you're constantly getting
knocked down again a lot of home depot
shopping from that tool box brother yeah
and I think the real gift that's built
into this whole thing is how you reframe
vulnerability like we tend to think of
vulnerability as a weakness or you know
somebody who's soft and and you embody
it in a completely different structure
to show people that it is it is strength
like if you want to be hard and you want
to be strong
vulnerability and open-mindedness are
the keys to that Kingdom as you said it
perfectly they're the one thing that
made me who I am today
is being vulnerable it's breaking myself
down to the absolute rock bottom and
being able to tell people who I am and
that's how I fixed it literally you know
looks at my in the eyes you know what
man I have a whole bunch of character
problems character flaws I've lied about
this I've cheated here I'm insecure here
this isn't the real me I lied to you
about that I wanted your acceptance in
life all those things happen but the
thing about is that we get judged so
quickly about who we are we don't know
we don't go to the to where it happened
you know life created this person me
life life created me to be this [ __ ]
up person that was back in the day and I
had to realize man that's okay man it's
not my fault now I can go back and fix
this [ __ ] though mm-hmm so a lot of this
isn't your fault while you do some
things you do while you feel the way you
feel but no one's coming back to save
your ass you have to go back to where
this [ __ ] start it wherever that place
is for everybody and have the courage to
go back there and start fixing what
broke you mm-hmm and that's and that's
why I was like hey I'm [ __ ] up I will
go back and fix this stuff you got to be
honest with yourself
I was it percent where you're at I was a
percent on like that oh is ugly yeah it
was funny about is that as you're trying
to fix yourself and dig yourself out of
this deep hole that life Society and you
helped you helped also those people who
you saw down there in that hole who are
there with you who your friends and
people who you counted on because you
the people in the same situation that
you're in in life those people becomes
your friends and second you try to get
out of that situation become better
those people are in that in that grave
and that dozen is yanking at your heels
man say go get no come on back here
[ __ ] yeah you make it make me
feel like [ __ ] right you getting out of
this hole who the [ __ ] do you think you
are so I get it all the time now
people would constantly remind me of who
I used to be back in the day and they
always come out of the Woodworks man
versus man still happening you know what
when you come from a small small town
and you come from place that a lot of
people don't want to come out of it and
get out of it and all you want to do is
become somebody when you have the small
town mentality real mentality you've got
to be able to get out and let your mind
see open-mindedness because a small town
what it does to you is it closes your
mind completely closed your mind not
everybody
this isn't everybody a lot of people you
have to be able to go out there and
create open mindedness you need space
you need space to see the world like a
lot of racism a lot of a lot of
ignorance in the world it comes from
people not being out and seeing other
things seeing other people seeing all
kind of [ __ ] but that's what we judged
so harshly because our minds are so
closed to the reality of of life period
have you been back to Brazil I went back
to Brazil a couple of times and I have
nothing wrong with Brazil because once
again you can't with another thing about
growth is you can't hold on Hey
mm you can't want to hate and see once
you take a different step so I didn't
take a step out of my life because like
what you're not once you're in that hell
that's all you see is what's in front of
you when I stepped out of it I saw
Brazil very differently there were a lot
of great people in Brazil some the best
people I knew were from Brazil but when
you're in hell all you see is a little
patch in front of you of the kids that
are calling you [ __ ] other people that
spray-painted [ __ ] we're gonna kill
you on your car people put that [ __ ] in
your locker people put a [ __ ] on your on
your notebook in Spanish class that's
all you see you didn't see that my god a
lot of people [ __ ] like me here so
once you take a step back and see the
reality of the true ignorance that
you're dealing with from a small group
of people that
you get growth because you know I went
through a phrase in the book I talk
about man I was all about you know I was
all about black and only black when I
was a junior in high school college so
beat down I was the most ignorant I've
ever been in my [ __ ] life when I went
there I totally took everything all the
hurt all the pain this put it in one
[ __ ] filter
I gotta find people who look just like
me it just like me to find acceptance
that one you were doing the crazy
haircuts that's the crazy watch the
Malcolm X video every damn night now at
home is [ __ ] yeah so the last time you
were here we kind of recap your your
story chronologically and I don't want
to I don't want to spend a lot of time
on that but there's a lot of new people
listening so I think it's worthwhile to
kind of you know catch people up on
exactly who is David Goggins and and you
know where you were where you were where
you came from what you endured and how
you arrived at this place is there a way
to do that concisely I can do it pretty
quick I guess you know I was born in
Buffalo my dad was uh almost getting
drinks on bars and he was a very
insecure guy he was an alcoholic he used
to get women for favors so my dad I'm
not seen as a pimp
I always he's a pimp that's how I look
at it my mom said the proper way to say
this is that your dad used to get women
and he would exchange women for favors
so there you go that's pretty much
refused a pimp right he's a [ __ ] pimp
so basically um that's that's my dad he
was he was a guy that didn't care much
about anything but himself but he was
kind of a baller all right new OJ
Simpson big-time knew all the Buffalo
Bills him and Rick James her best
friend's mom so he had two
different-sized it was decided everybody
saw which was the side of its major - so
damn cool man
he's awesome and we lived on Paradise
Road the second that door was shut in
that house it was game on the real him
would come out it was a perfect Jekyll
and Hyde so when you're born into that
at a young kids and like you're getting
beat for no reason you know like you
know I'm not weapons or weapons man but
this guy would beat you for no reason
just because he was drugs because he saw
you do whatever
it's like kind of like an IKE turner
character I turn it probably on on
steroids right so that that's we was and
he was he was a perfect person for
psychological warfare the the beatings
were horrible but the mind torture was
the worst he got so deep in my head as a
young kid and that really [ __ ] up your
foundation you know when when you're
born man there's some there's some
sensitive years in there man
where your brain starts to develop and
it starts to give you self-esteem
courage confidence all those things and
my dad was stripping that away from
everybody and when you see your mom the
worst thing to do is when you see your
mom getting beat senseless at a young
kid that [ __ ] scars you permanently I
mean she was like a prisoner she's the
best time and what you guys had to do to
escape and get away from him is like
insane
so she was 19 when she went there and
she was an innocent 19 year old and she
came from a great family and she met
this man and totally just um it just it
was it was brutal it was it was very
sadistic the way the way she was
tortured by him in the way my brother
myself were and that year and that broke
me my brother up my brother loved my
father a lot he saw something very
different than I saw cousin Aaron my mom
and I would get beat my brother I'm not
calling him a coward by any means he
handled it very different than I did he
would go in his room he didn't want to
see the beatings I would protect my
mother so in that I saw a lot more the
violence I was trying to protect her in
me trying to protect her I really got
beat mm-hmm so when you're constantly in
that battle and that struggle and your
brother's going in a different room
because he didn't want any part of this
[ __ ] he hated it and he loved family you
know he loved his family and I became
the person like a man I'm not about it
and you had to shoulder the
responsibility this this idea within you
that you were responsible for making
sure that your mom would be safe and
that was hard for it you're okay because
we moved to that small town of Brazil
Janna I hadn't learned this ability I
was stuttering I was battling so much
[ __ ] that I'd never even told my mom
about because I because she was battling
her own demons so at eight years old I'm
looking for comfort
I'm like hey don't bother your mama's
[ __ ] you another man in the house and I
also become real protective of my mother
at a young age so I said whatever you're
going through man you're on your [ __ ]
home you're not gonna not gonna tell
your mom [ __ ] and she didn't find out
later through the school systems and
through me failing in through me you
know all these issues I went through she
found out a lot but you know I kept as
my self gift from her man and that
really was a hard task for me to to
raise yourself mentally when you're
already in the deepest darkest dungeon
of all time and I think that's where I
started really creating myself I had to
really start creating a certain pattern
a certain process a certain kind of
indestructible toolbox to handle my life
well you were on this trajectory to
nowhere pretty quick but the the kind of
inciting incident that starts to shift
your trajectory is is this Air Force guy
that comes in your life right like you
developing this obsession with the
military right and then you meet this
dude who survived that parachuting right
nuts matter shooting gone very wrong and
I become obsessed with this guy and that
in I mean correct me if I'm wrong but
that seems like the first sort of
glimmer of hope that you might find your
way and it different and it different
you know so now like I talked about a
lot it was it started off with the rocky
Rambo movies right so it was kinda like
my father it's not coming up but then my
fine met this got him Scott Guerin this
guy that felt you know hit a parachute
accident a guy crashed through his
parachute and he fell 13,000 feet pretty
much to his death because his his
parachute collapsed and he was you know
he felt 120 miles an hour to the ground
I mean in picture in the book it's
disgusting right
and so he hit the ground and I met him a
couple years later at this see a piece
of Air Patrol camp and I'm sitting there
and no kid was like amazed by him you
know I was like okay this is a great
story I'm a kid let's go
I'm sinner he comes out and I was amazed
by Rambo like at a you know I got a oh
my god this is the real RAM he came out
he had you know he got his throat cut
open did you know to open up his airway
so so I saw he got traked and
I saw all these different things like my
gun he came out talking all like Clint
Eastwood shared a story is all hardcore
and I started following this guy but he
know I've fallen so for a week long he
did push-ups and flutter kicks and I was
like man that is too real Rambo why do
you think it connected with you and not
with the other kids like what was it
inside of you that was you know
obviously searching for somebody like
that I was looking for strength my
entire life I was I didn't have any I
was a I was a really weak kid my dad
beat the living [ __ ] out of me and took
every I was strong as a young kid but me
protecting my mom for so many years in
that house my dad made me very afraid
because he beat the [ __ ] out of me every
time without mmm so in that I want every
man wants courage every man was strength
at least this one does so I found it in
every way possible if I would see a
strong guys like okay maybe he could
teach me so he didn't know anything
about me so time went on I left school
you know oh and then this guy was in my
mind we had zero money man like we at
one time within the $7 month place
government subsidized apartments not
reliving like a torrent our place
tonight yeah at this time I searched I
went on a $500 phone bill and back then
dude and having no money my mom wanted
to kill me I was in search of Scott
Garrett yeah no Google no good I don't
know there's a randomly calling up Basin
Air Force bases man calling Air Force
bases man hey do you know what Scott
guarantee me I'm like who's Scott gear
I'm like he's a pair of rescue me what
because you know parents mean they know
there's not a lot of them so I started
getting okay there's a PJ base here a
pair rescue base here so I started
tracking down pair rescue bases finally
Key West Florida
he's a scuba instructor down there Key
West Florida I leave a like a message he
calls back he gets ahold of my mom I'm
like I cannot believe this guy call me
back my first question to him was hey
man can I come stay with you for a week
he's like who the [ __ ] are you man he
knows the [ __ ] it was the guy let me
come stay with him for a week and that
was you were senior in high school I was
a I was a junior in high school it was
in my junior year pretty much
it's pretty amazing that he that he was
open to that he was open to it I think
he said about four words to me in the
entire week we we PT together and I need
to hear a word from him he you know he
didn't talk a lot he was an instructor I
would I would go to school or to scuba
school with him he would instruct I sit
on the couch for 10 hours sit in the
lounge on the [ __ ] couch for 10 hours
he come back pick me up we go for a run
you go home we ate fish every [ __ ]
day could we had to go out in the ocean
I don't you know like that guy go
lobster hunting I hate the [ __ ] water
I'm scared to death but this guy went in
so I'm going in and I left there was
just one big thing that's what I want to
be hmm I want to be a guy like that yeah
this this desire within you to find like
a strong positive male you know role
model right life I was looking hard man
yeah but it wasn't easy getting into
getting you know following that path for
you know it was a it was a hardest thing
within my life being a peer rescue man
trying to be a peer rescue man there was
a lot of things I don't know about and
not having a mentor and I haven't you
know Scott was there he really wasn't
you know I met him for a week I saw
maybe a couple times and I started
bucking the [ __ ] off him he was a busy
guy had a family so I was back on my own
and I did the best I could and trying to
be a pair risk and I finally passed the
ASVAB test after you know taking it
several times and you know when you
cheat your whole life in high school in
elementary school had about fourth grade
reading level so I talk about that a lot
in the book and I had to learn so much
school in six months and that's when I
really developed my work ethic people
think it's from running and everything
no it's not from seals not from running
it was from the countless hours teaching
myself how to [ __ ] read and write you
know we you know I had a tutor for one
hour one hour every single week is all
we could afford so for six months I saw
a two to one hour a week all the rest
was on me my mom was working three jobs
she was never home I said there's a
[ __ ] table I'm like I have to get in
the military that became mine so this is
the whole book is really about mindset
oh the whole game and I and I would
agree that people look at you
they want to talk about bad water and
all these races that you've done you
know eight 100 milers and eight weeks
and all this insanity right but really
this is all a product of hardening your
mind calcining your mind to use your
phrase and throughout the book what what
really you know makes it stand out is
that there are lessons throughout like
this is a book in which it would be easy
to think that david Goggins is the hero
but the reader is the hero which is why
you made this decision that's what we're
talking about earlier to have Adam read
it because you wanted the reader to see
themselves in this own journey and you
have these chapters or after every
chapter you have these challenges and
takeaways for for people to you know use
to change their own mindset but even
woven into the narrative you're breaking
away from the story to say look this is
what you got to do this is what I did
this is how you do it right and the
first one of these really is the
accountability mirror right which still
use but what I didn't realize was that
you developed that when you were like a
junior in high school you started doing
that yeah but it's not like oh I did the
accountability mirror and then
everything started working out for me no
I was like it was a it was a fix at all
no it was just it was a starting point
to start holding myself accountable and
how that came to be man my mom got a
letter from school and this is when I
had to reveal myself and all my secrets
the the secret came out man I wasn't
going to school that I had I had flunked
most of my classes I had my report card
in there for everybody to see one of
them and it was reveals enough than that
yeah it was not your pro taught thanks a
lot Richard preciate it
so yeah you put it in there I put it in
there maybe he'll talk about it right
now um it was uh it was it yes and very
very embarrassed report card and she was
like what is this and this was like she
didn't see any report cards in my life
and at this time she was frustrated not
with me well you and dr. that other
report card right how doctors so much
crap but she didn't really see that one
huh but I dotted all my report cards and
did some had to reveal myself and she
was like you know what man
you
you're gonna flunk out no that was a
conversation no mic hey we gotta do some
[ __ ] you know you gotta fail she had her
own demons her own problems that's why I
went to the into the bathroom and I was
like my god do you like this is a harsh
reality your mom is like you're done
mm-hmm how about you are on your own and
the ass fat was really the first real
challenge where you tried to show up for
something a hundred percent right
that was my first quarto and and what I
love about the book is you know there's
the grand huge challenges and
accomplishments but what I find most
inspiring are just the small little
things like these little details like
when you're when you've left that test
and then you're in the car and then you
go back in yes it's like things like
that that really touched me that was my
that was actually trying to be navy snow
as the day I was a different test right
yeah so that was a that was a very
emotional moment for me and I'm actually
there right now in my head talking to
you I remember that moment like it was
yesterday my I was a fat guy trying to
be a Navy SEAL now and my life had come
to this crossroad so I'm like man you
have to go right and no one was going
right everybody was going let them let
you have to go right and to know that
pain and suffering I was about to endure
by going right the amount of
accountability and failure I'll get the
witness and suffer by myself alone on
this journey it was daunting so when I
finally got to the ASVAB test and I was
taking for my very last time to get into
the SEAL Teams or to try to even try out
they were supposed to tell me my score
and I went back out to my car that took
I was on some computer tests and I know
I used computer I was wigging out about
that [ __ ] because the first time I took
it was like something like notebook we
opened a scantron sheet and you bubble
it in with a number-two pencil and [ __ ]
you turn in
I saw a computer and I was like oh [ __ ]
with this [ __ ] with it oh my god like
it's on the computer so I wigged out
there and I had to get a 50 on
mechanical comprehension and I just like
the third time you taking the test right
this is my second time so I took it
three times for the Air Force and twice
for the neighborhood so this is my
second time for the Navy and they're
like hey this is it man you know you're
done
you're too old you have a limited amount
of time to lose 106 pounds and you take
his ass Bab again there's so many things
that's crunched down my head and so when
I took the test I knew I had a good
enough score to get in the Navy but to
be a seal had to score high on
mechanical comprehension of 50 so the
first time I got a 44 on mechanical
comprehension so I'm sitting there and I
take the test and I hit Send sentiment
is out in outer space somewhere and but
I knew it popped up at the
administrators desk and he's not
supposed to tell me [ __ ] he tells you
sit down take your test and you leave I
walked out got my car or I was walking
around the car whatever doesn't I got
going to find out man so I went in I
literally sat there everybody's taking
their test now I'm begging this guy he's
tell me I can't tell you [ __ ] it's
against government is guess rules
everything he opened it up it was okay
man
he said you got a 65 I said no man I
know I got him a chemical comprehension
and he scroll the page down it was
exactly a 50 and I literally like what
came through my body
cuz it's easy to talk about now to you
but no one knew at the time and energy I
put into getting that 50 right it was
pretty amazing yeah I mean what is that
what did that represent for you like the
opportunity for a new life to finally it
was in an opportunity for a new life but
the thing about it is I'm trying to be a
Navy SEAL
at this time I'm still tours and some of
my pounds they have more weight to lose
so think about this I put everything on
David Goggins to be a Navy SEAL it's
like going to the crap table with with
your last thousand dollars you say no
what I'm gonna put everything on this
[ __ ] mile on black and hopefully I
live now I'm broke I put my whole life a
guy that was scared the [ __ ] water a
guy that could [ __ ] tongs I've had a
reader right on being one of the hardest
[ __ ] on the plat think about
that [ __ ] a guy that came from nothing I
put my whole life and I'm gonna go out
here and put everything on David [ __ ]
guys to be a Navy SEAL not to go be a
[ __ ] you know Boy Scout or some [ __ ]
Navy SEAL and III look at that and I did
all this [ __ ] just to get the
opportunity to succeed that's what
that's what people don't [ __ ]
understand man if people see that the
end result I remember that guy say my
god man I can't believe what the [ __ ]
I've just done I put everything ruin
relationships ruin this ruin that put
everything on fact I have to become
someone in this world or I'm no good for
anybody
weird and where does that come from that
where did that compulsion that drive it
comes from a disgusting place of not
being fulfilled in your life of afraid
of dying having never accomplished
anything that's the fear that some
people run away from that people don't
want to face when you have a real fear
of dying and being just another person
that I live to pay the bills I made a
thousand dollars a month this is my life
I spray for cockroaches man if if that
makes you feel good that's great it
didn't make me feel good I wanted to the
first time my life after 26 years as 24
25 wherever I was I wanted to feel good
about myself and that was that was a
ticket yeah I mean you have this huge
reservoir this capacity to leverage pain
and circumstance to drive change within
yourself right to be able to not be a
victim but to look at pain as your
friend as a catalyst for growth and I
think there's a lot of people out there
look if you're in a enough pain that's
gonna move the needle for you there's a
lot of people out there that are in just
enough pain where they're willing to
just settle for what they have because
they're not in enough pain to change and
the fear of change outweighs the pain of
their daily existence you know the one
gift I have with all that being said
what you just said there is I have the
ability to see the end before the
beginning even begins and what that
means is I know that to get to the very
end I can see it right now
so before with the buds and I lose all
[ __ ] away
I saw myself walking across the [ __ ]
stage at 191 [ __ ] pounds guys I had
to get to get into the door I saw myself
six months a year later whatever's gonna
take me to do I saw myself walking
across that stage getting that [ __ ]
certificate of graduation from buds and
I was able to be there at 300 [ __ ]
pounds and that feeling that I was
nowhere near that [ __ ] feeling I was
able to put myself there a million times
every [ __ ] day and that feeling of
like my god that is gonna feel [ __ ]
amazing that's what made me suffer
that's what allowed the pain to be
realistic this is worth it I want to
feel for this [ __ ] next 18 months
every 18 [ __ ] months to find becoming
a v6 if I maybe you know just get
through but 18 months six months took me
18 that's what woke me up every [ __ ]
morning was I'm gonna put myself through
this much [ __ ] pain and suffering for
a few seconds so it is a few seconds of
joy it's so [ __ ] worth it man and so
people don't get so I'm able to put
myself at the finish line you know I
have no finish line but at the finish
line of an event before I even start the
[ __ ] to say how are you gonna
fill it into this well visualization is
one of the challenges and part of that
is not just visualizing success or
living in the reality of achieving what
you're setting out to achieve but also
visualizing how you're going to navigate
all the obstacles that are gonna get
thrown in your path right visualizing
this is my biggest tool of life that's
why I've been able to put myself in
Coldwater put myself in a hundred mile
race millions of times before I've done
it and I'm able to go through the race
and see I'm gonna feel at Mile 50 almost
to the almost to the exact Zac feeling
right so when it comes up it's no
surprise no surprise I've already done
this in many times and that's the one
thing I practice in practice and
practice and practice overnight but also
the most important thing is I practiced
that feeling of accomplishment I'm gonna
have my sauce and done with the crazy
thing about the ass fast
is that in addition to having to pass
this test
and get that 50 you also had to lose a
hundred pounds and like what like 30
days or some creature it was less than
three months right okay three months so
but you compartmentalize these two tasks
and say look the first thing I got to do
is I got to pass this test right because
the weight doesn't matter if I don't get
that 50 and you shelves or put off
losing the weight to focus on the
academic end of it until you you know
completed that hurdle and then you
looked at the weight stuff I'm like that
now that I've done yeah it's like being
focused on one thing at a time I have to
be very present in everything I do like
right now I'm with which role I'm not
thinking about [ __ ] but rich role and
with the fuss coming out of your mouth
right now that's what that's what gives
me a huge advantage in life especially
today in this day and age with so much
[ __ ] going so fast and everybody wants
to keep everything going everything up
and everything I want to be the grace
you know the greatest multitask of all
time not me if I put my hundred percent
into what's in front of me I will
destroy it if I'm out here just
multitasking this [ __ ] I'm gonna
half-ass everything I do so that's it is
the most important thing the world of me
is being focused at the task at hand and
it's getting harder and harder to do
that because there are so many
distractions and it's so easily - it's
so easy to distract yourself yes you
don't ever have to be bored again with
these things in our pockets
no but the one thing I'm most scared of
in the world is losing losing touch with
the the best thing in the world is is
your mind your mindset how you can
picture yourself how you can focus how
you can drive how you can put yourself
in so many situations get out of it
because those headphones were listening
to those those phones that that we
googled to find information there's so
many situations in my life where that's
just not gonna help me it's not gonna
help me and you're able to just turn
that off so fast because I know please
help me none of that stuff is ever help
me mm-hmm
none that stuff Sarah helped me would
has helped me has been me alone getting
my [ __ ] together and being accountable
for who I'm not and who I want to be
stolen has helped me so you get in you
you get the opportunity
to become a Navy Seal and then you end
up going through buds three times it's
like yeah Merry Christmas got lucky man
unbelievable and the stories of what
that entailed are like so vivid man
unbelievable well I was uh I was very
fortunate to go through three times and
not in this a distich way in a life
changing growing way I found out so much
about myself through going through that
training three times and I went through
the hardest part of the training three
times you know after the first so first
phase is a crucible man and that's where
I was at for three times I spent most of
my time and buds in first phase and the
hell week in the hell weeks and being in
that grind and in that grind I got time
to examine myself I caught the live
autopsy and also examine other people
because I was really good about putting
people way above me because I was I
wasn't [ __ ] I was never nobody so for me
to be on the same stage as these great
wannabe Navy SEALs and bus train like my
god you guys are amazing I actually got
here with you all thank you so much for
allowing me into play but as I was there
for so long I got a really good chance
to sit back cuz now the cold waters its
water now it smaller code anymore your
mind starts to change they said get in
the water most people think about it for
you
it became my life so I started learning
that if you try to change your mindset
versus it being like oh my god this
sucks
I became a professional blood student so
I wasn't gonna leave until I graduated
so I started realizing if this is my
home this is what I am
I had to always reset the bar I had to
reset my new norm there always had to be
a new norm so one thing we don't do is
we don't have a new norm my new norm is
you get up every [ __ ] morning at 4
o'clock and you suffer
this is your new norm that became my new
[ __ ] life most people want to get out
of it I said no I [ __ ] this is
your new life this is who you are you
your new norm is you wake up and you
suffer and I started realizing if that's
my mentality
this should ain't hard anymore
your [ __ ] new normals you wake up
you're getting the [ __ ] cold water
you get a beer - the shit's [ __ ] done
whenever they say you're out you get out
so my new norm so I I do that now today
my new norm now is if I'm doing a toys
in my run your new norm now man is you
[ __ ] or doing two hundred [ __ ]
miles the Roger that mentality that's it
man so at what point during this buds
experience do the instructors start to
take notice of you in a in a way that
separates you from the pack there's a
SBG or these guys that are like they're
starting to go hey man this this this
this dudes cut a little bit differently
SBG noticed it he noticed it in my
second how weak because I really and
this is no lie I'm very open about my
life spoken about this I really started
to enjoy the fact of seeing what the
human mind was capable of and seeing
that what is so horrendous there's so
much joy and glory in this [ __ ] and when
you see other alpha males I can you know
SBG in the book he's all he was one of
the hardest hardest guys in the SEAL
Teams he's looking at you like the [ __ ]
is wrong with you you know like you know
like well they start testing you like
they're like let's play this out right
and there's that story where he makes
you swim Wednesday night and that [ __ ]
me up because I like my knee was you
know it was broken it was it was [ __ ]
up bad it's Wednesday of hell week and
all the boat crews have passed the surf
zone and I just got a tour it all shot
my knee cuz I'm not gonna I'm let's go
ma'am we're going and it's [ __ ] like
it's real late at night and it was
[ __ ] raining and the class has passed
the surf zone and I'm still not big fan
the [ __ ] of water the ocean is very
unforgiving and I had this big life
jacket on and SPG's okay follow me man
sorry running a mile down to the boat
cruise rat I'll pass the surf zone I'm
thinking hey we could wait for him to
come on in he goes hey man get AK in
like you [ __ ] him like put on my hat and
said go out and [ __ ] get him and I
was on my own there was no like there
like swim buddies like it so I can buzz
you for swim buddy yeah and when he said
that to me I said are you in my mom see
this [ __ ] is joking he's got me
Joe commit it's what he must have been
thinking like I'm gonna break this guy
like this is gonna be the moment I think
that's what it was but but we're now
we're you know we're pretty tight now
and he said now that wasn't at all
he said you one of the only people in my
tenure act as a buds instructor that
were ever done that with he said I knew
a person like you would have found this
a challenge and I had to dig deep
because I didn't look at him and say hey
man I'm not doing that [ __ ] even though
I think I could it because there's no
swim buddy you know you don't go out
there Wednesday night after like 80
hours of hell week and you're like
seeing stars and [ __ ] like I'm like I'm
during the day time you see him boasting
are out there I'm here to loosen it all
over the place he sent me out there I
was like okay this is my time to show
him the best [ __ ] in the world
that it's on so I got my [ __ ] man I went
out there and did it and it was a it was
a iid tell it well on the book but it
was a it was a moment that I started
realizing I'm starting to separate
myself now yeah so there's two kind of
themes that emerge from that one is this
idea of taking souls all right this this
this sense that hey I came from nothing
and I'm here amongst the best and then
starting to realize like hey these
people are human right how can I get my
tactical advantage right and you explore
this idea of taking souls which which
essentially is going places no one else
is willing to go track with their heads
I see right yet to get like the upper
hand on that on everybody else when you
grow up weak and you start to master
your mind because my whole thing is
whenever I'm whenever I'm weakest
something wherever I'm scared of
something I master it I was a weak mom
you know a weak-minded person so I
mastered my mind and it mastered in my
mind I mastered the human mind and I
realized why I'm no longer just people
why I don't like to put people in a
pedestal cuz we're all [ __ ] up around
way we all have demons some people hide
them better than other people so I know
we all have them but I mean knowing that
under the most alpha males are very
fragile very fragile they never want to
see another person harder than them
especially in that coming round you go
attach the Eagle altar is strong Eagle
will [ __ ] you up every time
ego is serious so if I can hurt your ego
I got you so by me having such a fragile
ego growing up all this was my event I
was doing a live autopsy on how [ __ ]
up I was I was like hey this [ __ ] me up
I bet it [ __ ] other people up too so I
started using all these different tools
and tactics to get in the structures
heads and taking souls that's what
happened man
we were Wednesday freezing [ __ ] cold
everybody's jackhammer and everybody's
everybody wants to you know everybody's
just want to get through it now
jackhammer ins when you just can't stop
[ __ ] you can't stop shivering you know
you're sitting there this uncontrol be
jackhammering and the instructors take
great pride in watching you suffer they
do we're you know in in a sick way it's
kind of funny you know you know you were
there once as a student now your
instructor but I knew how would I be
thinking if I was in this truck I would
love seeing this sadistic [ __ ] go on but
what went out what wouldn't I like to
see I would hate to see some guys just
looking like this is just another
[ __ ] day on the [ __ ] beach and go
[ __ ] yourself I would hate to see that
so as I don't want to think like that
when they did it they were harder they
were harder yeah everybody's hoarse I
see know what man
it's time you all I can't fight you
you guys can [ __ ] me up all day long
that's your job and I love your job I
love what you guys are doing you guys
making us better but now I want to take
the tactical advantage I'm gonna start
[ __ ] with you so I got my boat crew
Bill Brown I had Chris Kyle on my boat
crew American sniper had a couple of
hardcore [ __ ] and everybody
right now is kind of like in their own
world let's just get through this man I
can't wait til Friday so we can graduate
how we can get going I said let's go
ahead and have some fun I said we're
gonna start [ __ ] with these guys so the
evolution here was we Scott dude with
Matt check you know we're stripped down
to nothing and they're checking us out
making sure we're good you know check in
front of Mon you're checking for [ __ ]
up knees my knees all jacked up but they
give me shots and [ __ ] and I was like
the boat crew leader of boat crew tuned
so I'm gonna front the boat and I tell
our guys this we're going to do the boat
like on our heads salt was we're
supposed to lift the boats up above her
head sorry God dude but when your this
week
in this fragile this tired their boats
heavy so there's a thing you can do when
you do boat presses so you can get the
boat like this toss it up toss it up and
catch it and that shows like you're
jacked up so everybody's holding the
boat and they're shaking and both
starting to come down their head and all
the boat crews are all lined up and
they're [ __ ] up and I'm looking at
that and I turn around my book I said
guys it's time to [ __ ] take some
Souls anybody what the [ __ ] you talking
about
I said she always [ __ ] instructors
out here on their [ __ ] jackets and
freakin coffee and laughing a smile and
[ __ ] I want their [ __ ] faces to go
straight up [ __ ] numb so we're gonna
do this we're gonna start boat pressing
this [ __ ] just take my leaf
trust me you'll get energy from it we
start throwing this boat up in the
[ __ ] air cache the toilet for kiss
and without yelling can't her [ __ ]
boat crew - we're yelling our [ __ ]
ass off and we doing it and they make a
stop like what the [ __ ] let me stop I
look at these instructors and their
faces literally look like someone like
just like took their sold-out Cod no
other mines were like they were thinking
about themselves like what the [ __ ] just
happy man I know me almost I could've
done that how they doing it so the rest
of time going through hell week it was
like we just you know we owned it right
boat crew - we won every single race we
were just dominating and it was uh it
was a strong boat crew and that's we're
taking Souls is uh there's a few taking
soil stories but that's one of them yeah
and and part of that is learning how to
be a leader like when you're dealing
with these alpha males and these huge
egos there's this tendency to just try
to outshine the next guy right you tell
an example there's another guy who kind
of proceeds along that path right and he
realizes very quickly that he's not
gonna make it because he doesn't know
how to build camaraderie with the other
guys right right
talk about mr. Dobbs he's a good friend
of mine still to this day and he went
into that place man and I knew where he
was going isn't my throat hell week and
I knew Sean real well but I knew he was
real arrogant he had a serious
shipowners so like I do I still do I got
that controlled every now and then it
got me in a lot of trouble sometimes
but I knew he had it I knew that chip on
your shirt not being controlled it will
it will get you [ __ ] up and it cost
him a lot going through buds and I saw
the look I saw the look because I once
had to look and I was going through
prayer rescue school and something got
so hard and your mind can't process the
hardness you don't know the the the the
right tools to get through something
hard because you've never been
challenged before I could tell he was a
superhuman that nothing ever challenged
them but I knew because I'd been through
hell week a couple of times I knew
[ __ ] don't don't underestimate
that [ __ ] it will it will find a [ __ ]
demon and will bring out some
insecurities in you and it did and I it
was like maybe 30 hours in the hell week
or something like that I'm looking over
at him and I smiled at him we're we're
standing just like this in line and he's
getting his med check and doctors
looking at him and talked it happened
just to be beautiful timing and I'm
sitting there I'm getting meth checked
and I'm looking at him and his eye says
he's a thousand-yard still looking right
through me he's getting mad checked and
I'm looking at him and before this
happened I told him I said don't
underestimate this [ __ ] man he
was I can't ever see myself quitting
[ __ ] Goggins I go watch out I go watch
out I got this [ __ ] we'll get in
your head I go the end is a long way
away so we're sitting there I - I and he
didn't see me I'm right in front of him
and I could tell you thinking he has
that quitting mind starting up now look
at him I go I told you [ __ ] I
told you [ __ ] and next thing I
knew man a car pulls up and he he rolled
out rings a bell he rings to Bill any
quits but uh it was he's a great human
being hard [ __ ] it it doesn't
make you you know when you quit
something like that man it's a huge
lesson learned that I can't go into
anything thinking that there's nothing
that's not going to get in my way you
gotta be prepared for all those
obstacles right well on this theme of
the reader being the hero here like what
is the what is the takeaway on stealing
Souls
thing because that's that's one of the
challenges well
there's tons of takeaways with that one
man it's about finding energy and
strength when you have none like a lot
of times in life like that situation
right there man it's the worst time of
your life there's energy all around us
that we think that we have to have asked
to come externally a lot of times we
have like a TV in front of us watch
somebody listen to a podcast listen to a
great music a lot of times in life is
[ __ ] quiet and those are the times
when you want to run and hide you got to
be able to find energy you got to make
up games makeup tricks makeup whatever
you can to get to the next evolution of
life so taking souls is just another way
it's not about hurting the person you're
against it's about finding the tactical
advantage in every situation you [ __ ]
physically can to get to the next you're
trying to inch further to the goal line
and you don't want to what is that goal
line the goal lines whatever it is for
you for me I want to get through hell
week now I won't get the help with a you
know with my head up high being strong
I don't know what the goal is for
everybody my goal has been very
different for most people but you're
trying to find energy and strength to
stay in the fight
to continue on until you get that second
wind the second win is coming whenever
the second win maybe for you it's coming
but what happens is we get so stressed
out that the end is so far away that we
just can't find another foothold another
handhold
so we jump off the cliff from each fall
there's another one you got to find it
so taking soil is one way to do it
hmm well as you as you progress through
this this journey that you're on and
you're winning these victories along the
way this idea kind of comes comes upon
you which is this drive to be uncommon
amongst the uncommon right you you
mentioned about a few moments earlier
that you started distancing yourself
even from the seals themselves like okay
I've done this I've distinguished myself
amongst these guys like now what's the
next challenge how can I push myself
harder like who
who you know what are the other
circumstances I can put myself in to be
the hardest [ __ ] on planet Earth
which was kind of the driving impulse
Ryder needs all of this right right so
elaborate on that a little bit so for me
that's why I want to become a Navy SEAL
I wanted people to push me outside of my
comfort zone every day you know and I
thought this was gonna be the absolute
best platform to do that these guys the
stories I heard after buds it just gets
harder and I didn't see it that way
because buds is just to become the sea
that's right like my god I can't imagine
what the [ __ ] gonna happen
but what happens to a lot of people not
everybody can't speak figure out not
everybody buds breaks people down to the
point where you don't want to be broken
down again like that to me that was
exactly the exact starting point for my
journey in life that was a starting
point for me for a lot of people it's
the finish line and I didn't see it that
way for me so that's where I started
becoming uncommon among common people is
where I started realizing that you put
people in a pedestal that you shouldn't
that you you got to get in there
yourself and examine people serious
really about yourself so once I got in
there real I say these are this normal
people
yeah there are a lot better than some
they're able to get to I know a lot of
people who get through Navy SEAL
training but you know there's a lot of
mystique behind behind all that stuff
and as you talk to go through and you
start to break it open a little bit you
know a lot of horror guys but you know I
want it more I want it more and this
this is your strength in certain
respects it's a superpower that you have
but it's also your Achilles heel
big time big time I talk about in the
book a lot - one thing that hurt me a
lot was I thought everybody weren't the
same thing I wanted and everybody wants
the same thing you [ __ ] won everybody
wants to give it four o'clock in the
morning and beat herself and find more
about themselves and she liked that and
I thought the seals did well through it
oh yeah yeah I thought the seal was
death but that's what you know because
every book you read that's what that's
what everybody does so I always hook
line and sinker so that mentality that I
had it kind of put a bad taste off you
know once I realized it not everybody
was like this in the community
and I was like you know what man so then
I started having chips on my shoulder I
had my own little thing I was doing with
a couple guys working out i mon Dieu mon
little thing and when you start doing
that stuff and you start to drive
yourself away from people you know and I
was already different as it was you know
even if I didn't do that I already came
in being very different like I tell
people I was a part of the Navy SEAL
Teams I wonder part of the Brotherhood
right it's not going out and partying
I'm not going out no that's not me I've
never been me though like if I was in
the college if I wasn't a Bigfoot I
couldn't be part of a fraternity man I
would never join a fraternity ever I'm
like a [ __ ] you all Matt got my own [ __ ]
going on over here man
go [ __ ] yourself that's me I don't like
fraternities so just me when you join
the SEAL Teams you're joining a big
fraternity so I was already asked out so
then when you're asked out not wanting
to hang out I wasn't a dick I do
[ __ ]
that's me so I I grew up wanting friends
at a young age and once you get
self-esteem is so you know who you are I
was comfortable you don't liking me but
I'm not hanging out and they need to get
to another step further with this being
hard mentality of if you guys aren't
doing what I'm doing you guys aren't
[ __ ] so I did a lot of things that push
people the wrong way that rub people the
wrong way and in that we're being in the
fraternity
it's like a big soap opera it's like the
[ __ ] guiding light and you know
people start not liking you for certain
reasons people know who the [ __ ] you are
rumor mills start happening then I have
two heart surgeries people think I don't
want to [ __ ] deploy overseas
well gah girls don't want to fight he
wants to run but I'm not gonna say a two
heart surgeries I couldn't even go fight
so this a lot of things happened and
within that it's life yeah so it
ultimately that hurt your military
career it didn't hurt it didn't no meet
me looking back on it it I was who I
wanted to be I was who I wanted to be so
hurting it I don't think hurting it is
being an Air Force
what do you see as being a ranger you
know my goals were finding the baddest
me on the planet working with the
baddest guys on the planet and the heart
surgery's hurt me a little bit but what
I realized is I've got a lot of growth
from examining people you know my my
insecurities their insecurities my
military career was absolutely stellar
you know not many people have pulled off
honor man everywhere I went and done the
things I've done
I didn't deploy as much as I wanted to
yeah I went to Iraq stuff like that but
I wanted to play a lot more with with
the heart services keeping out of
training for four years that hurt me a
lot but all in all there's not many
people who've done some of the things
I've done right so not satisfied with
just being in the Navy SEALs you decide
you want to go to Army Ranger School yes
sir and you go and do that yeah and you
distinguish yourself there so you know
when the dust settles you've done Air
Force
what does it call the tak tak PE air
control party uh
Navy SEALs buds and then and then Army
Ranger Ranger Delta selection twice
right exactly so what how did that play
out ultimately so it does selection I
went the first time when I was it so
with both time as a Navy SEAL which is
very found upon because we have our own
little group there yeah you know DEVGRU
so how that even came to be was after my
second platoon where me and my guys
didn't get along you know we had a great
deployment but we can't get along bottom
line once again it's how life is when
you come back in a fraternity like that
rumor mill flat you know goes around and
maybe Goggins has a badass who don't
work with him whatever whatever so I
didn't get my orders to go to dev group
I actually screamed for DEVGRU didn't
get picked up or I got picked up to go
to the screening process I pass the
screening process was going to Green
Team a lot of these [ __ ] things than
we knows about but anyway I didn't get
my orders to go to dev group so I said
you know what it's a good time to go try
out for deputy prefer for Delta Force so
I went there got messed up you know I
fell down a mountain my lady trapped in
Mountain or in some rocks broke my ankle
mathematical real bad then I had the
heart surgeries then I went back to
Delta and I was getting ready to get to
the very last day and what happened
there was I was getting real happy I'm
gonna be a delta guy this is the [ __ ] I
can't believe I'm back in the game and
once you let your mind get unfocused you
get lost out in the woods and out there
going through Delta selection it's a lot
of land navigation and if you're not
paying attention to that map and compass
and it was my last day before the 40
mile er and the 40 mile I was like a big
the big last thing you do and I was
gonna [ __ ] that 40 mile or up right but
I was your game that's my game man and
very one thing you're gonna be a man now
you put you know you put weight on my
back and go man I won't hurt you and I
got literally I was about two hours
ahead of time and I was just going
through thinking man I'm [ __ ] done
I made this [ __ ] I'm gonna go back in it
doing my [ __ ] I'm going back out the
fight man we know with an elite group a
Tier one asset I was so stoked my mind
got drifting away and I got lost and I
found myself lost
I got a reorient you know I got [ __ ]
back on track and I went to I thought my
last point was I saw another student I
said hey man we only got five points
there's no money we got six and I was
like 45 minutes from drop dead and I
made it by one minute you make about one
minute after making it about two hours
every day I was getting there two hours
early every day I don't know what the
standard is at Delta they don't tell you
[ __ ] and there's two vehicles you get
into man one vehicle goes to another
campground meaning you're still here and
the other vehicle goes uh goes to some
speed bumps back to your racks and
you're getting a [ __ ] airplane I went
that vehicle yeah that was it how many
soldiers are there though that have gone
through all of those programs I can say
honestly I'm the only one you're the
only one for a hundred percent fact I
know for a fact for a fact and I haven't
googled it looked at I know there's
nobody in the world who's willing
to say let me scream for delta force
twice let me go to Army Ranger school as
a Navy SEAL let me go to Navy SEAL let
me go be in three whole weeks let me go
to Air Force so my military career was
phenomenal there's uh there's a classic
quote look I think it's as I recall I
think it's when you decided you want to
go to Army Ranger School and one of your
guys say Goggins you're the kind of guy
who would like to be a POWs just to see
if you could [ __ ] do it
he was my oh I see my I actually still
talked him today of my first Platoon I
really respect the guy off a lot what's
like a pop his name by honors permission
right now - he was a great leader
because he understood me as a good
leader you have to understand everybody
that works with you he understood the
uniqueness that is me and I'm a very
different person you got to have a you
got to be a real [ __ ] man to
understand David Goggins and I give him
a lot of credit for this let me be me
and I and you know he went to that into
a DEVGRU but he said that before Ranger
school cuz I put a chit in a chit is a
special request [ __ ] I put seven special
request shits in to go to Ranger School
as a new guy in in the SEAL Teams it's
like why the [ __ ] are you trying to go
to Ranger School man as a seal and back
then they were sending some Navy SEALs
there for punishment you know they send
a few there and I was going because I
was like begging to go I'm like there's
another challenge out there that sucks
that people don't want to go to that I
can grow from that can see some more on
common [ __ ] out there that want
to get hard and get after it and I
always found out one thing when you're
in training that's what you find how
people really are I found the best out
of people in training that's why I love
buzz that's why I love Ranger school
because but once you get out training
very few people keep that same mentality
it's like hey oh thank God I'm done with
it that's why I always love going back
to scratch mm-hmm yeah and the cool
thing about Ranger school is you show up
and they strip you of all of everything
so you don't know who anybody is
Frank is there any of that kind of [ __ ]
no there's no right now and they
purchase presumed that you must have
gotten in trouble right that's the only
reason you'd be there right so tell me
tell that story about so their words so
before I showed up to Ranger school man
there were a couple of Navy SEALs got
sent there for punishment reasons and a
couple of them quit you know like not
because it was too hard I imagine
probably cuz you don't [ __ ] you I'm not
gonna be here for punishment I'm gonna
get my ass kicked again with you Navy
SEAL training so it just came with the
attitude of being there so a couple said
I'm out so that gave some of the seals a
bad reputation that Ranger school and
then I show up I show up and I'm like
yeah I want to be here next I was just
another guy that got in trouble not
knowing that I begged to come here and I
beg to get beat on for 69 days and
starve and lose 56 pounds like I lost so
it's like day three and they have you
know an army guy raw strip to rank on
this David you know I'm this Goggins and
whoever this is just your name I mean
you could be a [ __ ] major you could
be a general and you're just Thomas
that's all the [ __ ] you are I mean they
don't care so I'm hiding out I got my
little Navy name tag on so they can tell
him a navy guy I'm a little Navy hat you
know say so you know I'm a Navy guy I
stand out and once it's not many black
guys in Ranger School so I'm in the back
hiding out and they tell the you know
they tell the guy come up here you know
you know you're the first sergeant in
the First Sergeant usually Ranger creed
so the guy goes up there and he goes uh
he [ __ ] it up and then go hey they look
right at me I know for a fact
oh we seen him back there where the hell
economy doesn't know this [ __ ] I was
like [ __ ] I've been studying
this range of Cree for a year this what
I'm saying in my head I get there man
recognizing that volunteer as a ranger
foolin has my chosen profession I was
never told STIs
our hospital arrangement see what you're
done I went on it nas in fact there is
more at least he's like what the [ __ ]
somebody had said the whole [ __ ]
range of Creed next thing I knew you say
you knew first sergeant that's a [ __ ]
now not only am I going through one of
the best leadership school if you have
to be dialed in all day long when I'm
not out in the field getting graded I'm
now in garrison having to be in charge
of all these
[ __ ] guys in Bravo platoon so Bravo
Company sounds like guys it was a I was
always had to be on the whole time Roger
that Roger dad sounds like [ __ ] man I
guess I'm in charge now the whole time
but I never got fired you know most guys
going through that you know you get
fired that's what led me to you know
getting the the honor man award right
one of the things you don't talk a lot
about is your deployments mm-hmm you
talk about that experience in Malaysia a
little bit only briefly in the book so
I'm just wondering what the rationale
behind like are you not allowed to do
you just think that it wasn't relevant
to the story we're trying to tell well
the thing about it is is uh I deployed I
fought in combat stuff like that first
of all it's hard to relate to that
second of all I to get all kind of
[ __ ] approvals from people to get
that in the book and talk about it and I
want to go through that process of hey
can I put you know what I did in Iraq in
the book and stuff like that in the book
and I want my book to relate to people
you know there's enough Navy SEAL books
out there talking about you know running
gun and shooting them up stuff like that
that's never been I don't want to be
known as a Navy SEAL you know I talk a
lot you know people want to ask me about
it you know Navy said that was a snippet
of my life you know I was a snippet of
my life and I want to be known as
somebody much more than that who did a
lot more than that so my book is about
helping people and I can't help people
through well I didn't combat mm-hmm I
can help people by what I went through
in life life itself and I went out to I
mean it was it was intentional to make
this book about how can these stories
resonate and help people and you know it
wasn't like a let me kiss my own ass so
that's why I had to go there and do that
so it was it was a that's why yeah
well there's a you know the cover image
of the book is you in military uniform
and there are a lot of those other kind
of books out there you know Chris Kyle
and I know you you you're tight with the
luttrell brothers those have been huge
books and they become movies and
cultural you know very culturally
relevant and northing what is that I'm
not
war hero yeah I'm not I'm not I'm not
I'm not a war hero man like you know
there's a lot of heroes out there and I
don't have a great story to tell you
about war what is the climate though
when you're in the seals and then
somebody writes a book like my sense was
always that that was kind of frowned
upon it is found upon this to a lot of
things are frowned upon the SEAL Teams a
lot of things are you know that's that's
one of them
I don't care what you do you know it's
your life and I'm not about judging
people for that but a lot of a lot of
seals don't like anybody going out doing
anything like that and I don't know if
it's a lot of jealousy or whatever I
don't care but it is it is found upon
for some people do that but I guarantee
you some of those guys if they did some
cool [ __ ] you know a lot of us don't do
cool [ __ ] yeah a lot of us he cometh not
a lot of cool [ __ ] so there really isn't
about it's not it's not some
vainglorious snow I'm where you're in
bad always telling crazy war stories no
it's not that at all it have to tell so
reader is the hero and and another one
of the themes that I want to kind of
explore with you is this idea of of
being the only right I'm just like a
recurring thing in your story right so
being the only and I actually talked
about with Adam I came up with with the
only there's a lot of onlys out there I
was the only black in lot of situations
and the only in about of color there's a
lot of you know there's gays lesbians
there's people who are white people who
just feel like they're not wanted in
society that's the only the only is
feeling like you're not accepted in any
society that you're in doesn't matter
what color creed race gender doesn't
matter it's just that you are in this
situation where you feel like you're
being judged you might be being judged
you feel awkward it's an awkward feeling
when you walk in a room and you're like
oh my god like I'm the only and that
comes with a lot of people and that's
where the only really came from because
I don't want to make like a black
situation I want it to be I want this
this is about people you are you
hero you are the hero of this book so I
wanted to be what's a word that can make
people feel like this resonates with me
that's only you know it's not about it
was about black about white or about
about being Jewish or Christian or
whatever so that's where it comes from
man it's about ownership of a lot of
people feel like no one understands what
the [ __ ] I'm going through right now and
that's the only right and that seems to
be something that you you use you
leverage to to get stronger
oh yes the only is a very powerful thing
for me and there's a lot of times my
life that I chose the only on purpose on
purpose just to see how I will come out
the other end of it and in the midst of
all of that how do I say this
for somebody that's listening to this or
they're reading your book and they do
feel apart from they feel alone perhaps
they have that victim mentality right
they're just the world's against me I
can't catch a break every time I try to
do this this happens it's some narrative
that they're spinning about their life
right like what's the first step out of
that well like I've said a million times
before the most important conversation
is the one you have with yourself you
wake up with it you walk around with it
you go to bed with it eventually you act
on it
sometimes you act on it good sometimes
bad you got to change the internal
dialog that person in your head that's
talking that [ __ ] to you until you
change the internal dialogue in your
head until you callus over the victims
mentality that the world is out to get
you because of you are the only you got
changed that [ __ ] man yeah but you don't
understand my life David yeah I do
that's the thing about it and that's why
I can talk about but yeah I get you're
saying a lot of folks don't under I get
that mentality I once had that mentality
that no one understands what the [ __ ]
I'm going through and if you keep that
mentality you're gonna stay in the same
exact spot that you're in that no one
understands me there's a whole there's
millions of people why do you think a
book that I saw published you know is
doing so well
with the story that's so [ __ ] up
people Ike I'll never forget what I went
to a publishing house like who's gonna
resonate with this story no one's gonna
buy this book I'm like are you not in
the world are you not in society you're
never alone everybody's going through
[ __ ] so when people get this mentality
of like you understand me you can throw
a [ __ ] rock to someone that can
understand you if they're willing to
break themselves down and stop hiding a
lot of people understand you mm but you
got to stop hiding and that's why I tell
people a lot of people are going through
[ __ ] they just hide better than you did
that's all they did
it was hiding better yeah it's easy you
know it's easy even even after you've
accomplished something to not rest on
your laurels or take a breath like
you're somebody who's constantly
constantly moving forward I'd sell it
but I think one thing that gets lost in
your story is that you are pretty good
about celebrating the victories along
the way and celebrating yourself I talk
about with my fiancee every single day I
talked about with her two hours today I
said we are [ __ ] grinding so hard
that we are losing the vantage point of
what we have accomplished today we got
podcast podcast interview flying do this
do that I like to stop stop it's just me
and you
and this mom-and-pop thing that we that
we're doing look at what the [ __ ] this
book is that right now it's crazy look
how many people were touching shut shut
up and this [ __ ] think for a second
that's the stop cuz all we did was talk
about this and this really I don't know
enjoy this for a second let's we have to
take time and rule out what the [ __ ]
we've accomplished that's an evolution
for you man huge huge different David
Goggins and even from a couple years ago
huge because you have to where's all
about I'm gonna keep on grinding that's
not what I'm saying what I'm saying
though is you have to respect what
you've done
take a second not live in it not sit
around and say I'm good
sit back and say let me look at the
vantage point now that I'm at we win
that's why you reset the vantage point
get the tactical advantage if you get
the tactical advantage too quick
and start fighting you gotta take a
second to take observation that where
I'm at what have I done I'm on the right
spot I'm obviously in the right spot
right now now we can go back to fighting
mm-hmm so that's what we're doing right
now and how did you how did you arrive
at that epiphany because I would imagine
there's a different version of you that
wouldn't allow yourself to be that
indulgent it's called you find peace I
never found peace until I got real sick
and you find peace by clarity and
there's no clarity when there's noise
there's always a schedule in front of
you to keep grinding at it so my
schedule is always there I'm still alive
and I'm still alive I'm gonna grind it
so I'm dead but in that grinding
schedule you have to have a point in
there where it's okay at 12 o'clock
reset the tactical advantage and look
and see where you're at at this new
vantage point stop for a second and
survey the field because when I was
doing well that this big long schedule
and in this schedule there was no take
up second see what the [ __ ] you've
accomplished if I did all that [ __ ] in
the military after I got on ER man at
Ranger School and I was a top leader
amongst 300 people when I got back to
that second platoon if I'd taken the
vantage point and said okay my god man
you've really grown as a leader I would
have attacked the situation that 2nd
platoon was differently when I was like
oh you guys it's [ __ ] you guys are
gonna work out this [ __ ] hard you
ain't you ain't hard like this I want to
learn I want to take a step back it's ok
hang on a second man you learned a lot
that's the tactical advantage you gotta
take that vantage point and take a
second to breathe and say you learned a
lot but when you learn a lot if you just
go back into the fight you never apply
what you learn you get that certificate
of graduation and go get it
remember what you learn and use it and
that's about taking that one second out
get on top of that mountain top looking
down so ok how would I have held this
years ago Wow I would really [ __ ] that
up this time let's not [ __ ] it up again
right so that that occurred not during
the heart surgeries but afterwards when
your body was broken and you got into
the stretching broken yeah it was a big
it's like when you go into my gives you
a knot and they tie a lot versus a ton
of knot to tie a lot and they say hey
can you undo this that was the inside of
my body mm-hmm but it forced you to stop
it made me stop yeah yeah I can no
longer because otherwise you wouldn't
you wouldn't have stopped I would never
realize I realize now no yeah I've been
goals isn't bluffing right okay man we
got a bench you because you need to
reflect the body would do that the body
would do that the body will say hey man
you've done a good job now we're [ __ ]
done and my body said you're done right
so you you have the heart surgeries you
make this return to ultras ameen dude
we've been talking for like an hour and
a half we haven't even talked about any
adult stuff but you know we talked about
that last time man you go out you're
crushing it and all these races then you
have the heart situation you have two
heart surgeries then you're back at it
again and then you hit this wall like
you you describe this classic
overtraining situation where you got
back at it and you were training
SuperDuper hard and then you showed up
and you were just flat right yeah I
thought it gain and weight overnight my
thyroid my endocrine system starts yeah
[ __ ] just shutting down left and
right I'm surprised it took that long
for you to have and like a severe
overtraining episode and yeah it was a
severe you know it was probably
overtraining mixed in with a lot of [ __ ]
you know the body was whacked it was
whack man and it just said you're done
go ahead hang up your shoes lay in the
bed it's time to die and how long did
that go on for it went on about five
years five years yeah so wait what
period of times us so you're looking at
it was bad water so before bad water
2013 is when it started actually walked
a hundred miles of that race to finish
it that was the way I was crewing Dean
that year yeah you were right on our
heels like most of the day and if I was
I walked that whole thing was on Dean
he was walking line sales Soho was not a
good year for I walked that almost whole
race I was cramping up so bad look like
an alien was in my quads they were just
doing this weird thing I was hydrating
salt like what the hell's going on my
body start shutting down then and then I
had like a period of time I was like my
god feeling my best and I crushed this
way it's called frozen otter and I was
like my god man I'm back no I wasn't it
was just my body saying we got one more
in this man before we give it up so 2013
is when it really started hitting hard
man it went off enough all the things
that you had to process that was
probably one of the hardest being told
you have to stop it was one of my
hardest but I have to be honest with you
it was the most eye-opening refreshing
time my entire life it was like it
really made me reset and it like what it
said to me was all right man we still
gotta find 100% mm-hmm
you can't run you can't work out so
that's why I went to school and I became
a medic you know stuff like that with
you know I started doing awesome
I literally reset so I'm always in
constant pursuit of my hundred percent
whatever that is if I can't run anymore
I'm gonna see what else I can do so it I
was real proud of how I handled that my
whole life got stripped from me and I
was at like 20 years in the military and
that my life was getting stripped man
and I couldn't run I couldn't work out
country [ __ ] anymore and I didn't lose
my [ __ ] all that train I'd gone through
mental training I'd gone through I was
able to utilize it to find a lot of
peace in myself a lot of joy and a lot
of self fulfillment mm-hmm and it was uh
it was actually uh not the best time
yeah well my favorite chapter in the
entire book is the final chapter chapter
well I mean I was just so because one of
the things I've always sort of thought
about you or been concerned about with
you is like is this guy gonna just go to
his grave grinding and just angry and
resentful avenging you know against the
world or is he going to be able to find
peace
gonna be able to be content is he going
to be able to find a way
- - you know find the joy and the
gratitude for these experiences or are
you just going to be fighting all the
way to the end man and you found that
right like I was so happy you don't like
read that yeah I found it but what's
great about it is I found it like I
still tap into it yeah do is it was
there a moment of thinking like if I if
I allow myself to experience joy and
gratitude that I'm not gonna be able to
be as hard that I'm gonna lose that edge
that distinguishes me no that's not at
all what it was was um I never felt that
my entire life
you're almost taught that [ __ ] when
you're born in a happy home and and
you're born around happy [ __ ] it kind of
comes out I never I don't laugh my dad
beat the laughter out of me when when
you can't read and write and you're
trying to hide out in classes and please
don't call on me and [ __ ] and you're
[ __ ] all scared of [ __ ] everywhere
you go you're nervous and you're being
and you're panicked and you're
stuttering and you know your whole life
is that [ __ ] there's not joy in that
[ __ ] that becomes who you are no matter
how much you change you're scarred so
people like my god man you never smile
never do this it's my life it's my life
so you got to teach yourself how to read
and write and also [ __ ] smile and say
it's okay
a lot of things aren't like you know man
why don't you do this like I don't judge
people that's why I don't judge the
people man you want smart looks so hard
like this read my book and don't forget
where I came from it's who you are
you have to undo that [ __ ] and no one
came down and trained me on how to be
happy how to find peace how do this now
that's why I'm so glad I found it
through suffering
the greater the suffer the greater the
peace I've found but you have to reflect
on where you came from from the dungeon
of Hell that I came from how to reflect
on that [ __ ] to find final peace and be
able to say WOW [ __ ] if you die
in this bed at 40 years old I'm the
happiest [ __ ] in the world
because I did it I piss people off along
the way some people don't like me Merry
Christmas whatever
but you can finally look in the [ __ ]
mirror and you can cuss on damn rich
roll [ __ ] and don't care what they say
about you be happy with it
the non-judgmental part is a lesson that
you have to learn the hard way too right
big time yeah big time
I used to hate people not liking me when
the hardest thing in the world for me at
a young age was my god I swore to fit in
I want to fit in I want you to like me
so that's a horrible [ __ ] place to be
in life because you lose yourself when
you want to fit in with people so badly
normal [ __ ] people know better than
you you do whatever you can to fit in
that's a bad place to be you lose
yourself and trying to create a
character that other people will accept
and the that's what I found a lot of joy
man this is guy this is me I'm speaking
the third personal [ __ ] up I got some
[ __ ] going on still working on myself
take it or leave you don't like me take
a number and get in line man and it does
that involve like a spiritual
perspective like what does that look
like for you I am a even though people
may not believe it for that cus mrs.
hilarious
I believe in God big time I've had this
voice in my head since I was a young kid
so what trained me was that voice and
I'm not gonna go God on you right now I
don't care if people believe in God or
not that's not my place I'm not here to
judge you you have your own life and
your own things to deal with this voice
in my head
guided me to a spot where I'm at today
and if you don't believe that you're
here for a reason
your life will seriously hurt and I
started looking at my life and all this
[ __ ] I went through as God put me some
God whatever you believe in put me here
to go through this and now I see all the
hundreds of thousands of lives I'm
changing by the hell I went through
there's a lot of power in that so my
purpose as I started going through this
journey instead of looking like woe is
me god man why the [ __ ] man why I so
looking at what's the perfect training
ground you knew exactly what you were
doing you know exactly what the [ __ ] you
were doing obviously you put me in every
situation possible to tell a story that
needs to be told
yeah looking back it's like every domino
is lined up perfectly to create the
person that I'm sitting across from
right now and also you took advantage
you leveraged all of those opportunities
to be that best version of yourself
mm-hmm I did as afraid of that I mean it
was a very scary scary road a guy who
was afraid of a lot of things to then
find power and fear to find power and
overcoming fear and to get time out
today where there's very few things I'm
really afraid of because I know how to
control it
I know how to manage it I'm not to work
it to my advantage now it's something
else man so I really challenge people to
really do a live autopsy on your brain
and the reason why I talk on my
childhood so much in this cuz I don't
want you to put a title on me because
once you title me as a freak you now put
yourself in a position where you can be
very comfortable in saying it's just not
possible for me yeah that's so important
because you have done so many crazy
things it's very easy to just say well
he's a crazy outlier that's it that's it
he's that guy he's that special guy nope
and that's the thing that makes me so
pissed off in this world man
the one thing that only thing gets me
mad nowadays is that so many people die
with untapped potential because they
think that someone else is [ __ ]
better than them and they were born you
know not with the greatest tools you
don't need [ __ ] you need the ability to
[ __ ] grind your ass into a fine
[ __ ] powder in that fine powder find
a way to build that [ __ ] back up
repeatedly that's possible yeah for you
what I love is that you go out on these
crazy training excursions and it's just
pair of running shoes and shorts along
is it man you don't have any crazy gear
nope I'm a sponsored [ __ ] or
anything like that no it's just at its
most purest form I found a lot in that
man always it has to be pure man like I
don't want people like the reason I'll
post a post what you're doing today
no no man this is my time how much you
[ __ ] know I'm doing today
this is this is my time this is my
growth factor but I think it creates a
lot of demand because when you do drop
that bomb once a week or whatever it's
like she'll look at it I'll be like damn
and that like an hour ago
hey man unless you mine know what's
going on in haha
you know it says it's all about giving
back in training uh-huh but I'm still
learning I'm still learning I'm not Yoda
yet what do you what do you still need
to learn and what are you still afraid
of honestly my biggest fear to this day
is and I say a lot and I say a lot and
it's it's going to heaven and being
judged by God and you know God has I
believe that God has this knows
everything about you from time you're
born when you're gonna be born when
you're gonna die when you to graduate
buzz whatever's going to happen - he
knows all this [ __ ] some people never do
what God knows you're capable of doing
because you keep you know we have
choices my biggest fear in life was to
was to get to heaven and God look at me
as I'm being judged and I was some fat
300-pound guy like I used to be that
still spray for cockroach it was a car
you know that's that's okay it's what
you want to do I didn't wanna do that
and I made a thousand dollars you know a
month I got to heaven and God laid out
this chart in front of me and they said
hey man look at this chart and had my
name on top and all this amazing [ __ ]
and I'm like that's not that's not me
man he goes that's who you were supposed
to be my biggest fear in life is that
one day if I ever get judged by
something someone some some energy force
that go up there and I failed the
mission whatever would ever force up
there thought I was to be some badass
and I went up there under achieved you
know I want that force up there that
knows everything to be writing as I'm
living and saying I had no [ __ ] idea
he even had this in him so I want to
just be the best I [ __ ] can and a lot
people say that I truly mean that and
what is it that you have to learn
i stuff learned me you know I I still
feel there's you know there's there's
times where as a human being I'm a human
and you you still fall back in these in
these ruts of life where you think that
you had a permanent fix cuz I'd done all
that nothing's a permanent fix man
that's why I grind every day because
nothing is permanent are you training
for anything right now I'm signed up for
the hurt 100 oh you actually got in it
and my schedule is so [ __ ] packed but
I'm hoping I have like literally a
one-day literally I can go out to run
the race and fly back ah so I - that one
is a race it is I think the 17th or 18th
or 19th it's in that it is that weekend
right in there that's a rare return to a
race I mean other than bad water
I've been there three times already yeah
oh you don't hurt three times on oh you
have okay yeah I've done three times and
I haven't done a hundred mile race since
that bad water 2013 I've done I've done
several ultras but 200 mile distant you
know my bias wasn't just not there it's
there now but now my schedule is so busy
but I said it's almost time man right
but I feel like bad waters your [ __ ] it
is the one that stands out amongst
everything as the thing you're always
trying to master it it was funny about
that I'm just now getting to a point now
where I'm being I'm gonna be real
dangerous nice to meet you out there
well listen man you're 43 now right 43
your prime I am you know this is this
the problem my life is my problem ultra
life
43 it was my best year was it yeah I
mean it's your your radon uncoil man I
think I I believe so I don't want to the
biggest challenge for you now is that
your life is so big and that's the thing
that I used to be this underground know
and the monk is what gave me my strength
I was underground much quiet so much
quiet in my life I saw all the noise out
you're that guy in the corner with the
hoodie on that's me man yeah
that's me that's mirus dangerous
[ __ ] try to man
so so we can expect another bad water
appearance oh for sure yeah for sure
that is that that
this will not end this will not end
without that [ __ ] right there
yeah well I want to I want to pivot a
little bit and talk about the takeaways
here for for the reader I mean we talked
about the accountability mirror a little
bit we talked about visualization and
taking souls but let's talk a little bit
about how journaling has been
instrumental in this journey that you've
been on yeah so basically I've been
journaling now for several years and I
should have bought my journal with me
man I mean I have several of them had
these little green military notebooks
that I've kept actually put a couple in
the in the book they're coming right out
but I write down my day and what I do is
I go back and study that day like
sometimes I might I might get sick I
might be over trained I might gain a
couple pounds here I might feel it
whatever that and then I it's like my
accountability journal of what I'm doing
with my life physical mental I had
eating journal all this [ __ ] and helped
me go back to once again study I'm a lab
rat and I study myself I'm like not
feeling [ __ ] up I go okay what I do
last week and usually I can find out
where I messed up last week you know how
much time travel I want some sleep and
how much I'm doing all this stuff and
and through journaling man you can
really figure out so much about where
you're messing up in life and what you
need to fix about yourself taking
constant inventory costing honest about
that and that's thing about you cannot
put [ __ ] in there yeah it's gotta be
a real a real journal about hey today I
messed up here today I should have been
a better person here and not just saying
it but actually trying to fix it
tomorrow do you extend that
accountability to including like
bringing in like a close circle of
friends and mentors so they know what's
going on or are you just accountable to
yourself like if somebody's looking at
this and saying well I could do that but
how do you feel about letting others in
on your goals and and and having like
external pressure to hold you
accountable no there's no external
pressure that's that's we don't need it
no you don't I mean but I think other
people oh yeah oh yeah
it no it's important to have circles
it's important to have like like I
talked about man like like that big
rabbit hole of bad people that you want
to get away from like if you're a drunk
you want to stop drinking you gotta get
away from those people you want to build
this nucleus around you of people who
are saying it's not okay to sleep in
today
we gotta get after it hey let me see
your journal you're supposed to be
running five miles they only ran three
you got to have those people some people
need those people hmm
and it's important but you want to get
to the point in your life it's real
important that you hold yourself
accountable and those people start to
fade away because you now got it you
want to be that person cuz they're not
always gonna be there to hold your hand
mm-hmm talk to me about the cookie jar
one of the most powerful weapons I have
man as a cookie jar and in times of need
even the hardest person forgets how
badass they are so I've been through a
lot of [ __ ] in my life when you're going
through a hard time right now you forget
all the hardship you when doored
so the cookie jar is a reminder that oh
I can get through this hard time right
now but you got to take a second or two
to reach into the mental cookie jar
let's say it's a fortune cookie
but in my mind my mom is about these
cookies knowing the cookie jar and
there's an Oreo chips or whatever that's
why got the cookie jar from but you got
to open up and say okay man I was in
three Hill weeks and I got through two
of them you know I was in Ranger school
I I endured being called [ __ ] I saw
these beatings I you know my mom
soon-to-be husband got got murdered I
saw all these I saw a little kid hair
get read about all these things aren't
do it alone I had to remind myself of
the strength and the power that I have
that it's in me it's just a reminder of
how badass you are
in hard times because you know we just
forget that that bad time consumes our
mind and we forget who we are
torching complacency you have to do that
every day man a lot of us are very you
become complacent you become very
civilized in life
you know the worst thing that can happen
to a person you become civilized you get
to that point where you believe that
you've arrived were you my god man I'm
up there near Michelle Obama on my book
I've done it man mm-hmm
I'm good you can coast I can't I'm good
enough to do her I got played your man
cards to [ __ ] do out to be a wildland
firefighter man I retire for the milk I
think I could go out there and dig fire
line for three miles on 43 mouths done
it you should just be flying first class
everywhere every blue in speech isn't
getting paid crazy caffeine in a hotel
kickin it man and that's exactly when
it's over that mindset right there to
meet his death I'm not saying you can go
as hard as you did when you were 20 or
not 43 but there's a new bar that you
must always set in your life and once
you become complacent and you become
civilized you've arrived you no good for
anybody and how do you keep that bar
high when most challenges now I would
imagine seem trivial compared to what
you've endured they are I go back to the
sewer in the sewers at $7 a month place
I once lived in as a young kid so even
though mentally mentally mentally and I
always talked about it I'll talk about
I'm always paying rent and that $7 month
place where I grew up in that nasty
little place I grew up in I remember it
I remember like it was yesterday and I'm
glad I do I never want to forget the
dungeon of where I come from even though
it's real spooky and scary and there's
no lights on in there there's cobwebs
and some creepy [ __ ] in there
some demons all those [ __ ] in
there made me dragons may be Who I am
today that's where the strength came
from you got to go back to the beginning
to to the fundamentals of life to the
very fundamentals that we're all like
playing basketball you gotta go back to
the fundamentals you just know you can't
always just stay up here you got to go
back to scratch that's a that challenge
becomes staying in tune with that that's
right you know what I mean because
life's getting better and easier for you
and bigger and there's more demands on
your time and like people are throwing
really
cool fun shitty yeah I'm always asked my
fiance my conversation on a weekly basis
is I cannot get away from who the [ __ ] I
am Who I am
is who I'm proud of I'm very proud of
the hard-working calloused hands
calloused mine human being that I
literally made this person with a lot of
help from above a lot of guidance from
saying you're gonna go left and you
should go right that horrible voice that
wouldn't let me get away from myself and
hide forever I listen to it I listen to
it and the only way you can set the
example is you have to always be willing
to work
I don't follow people who talk about
what they used to do in life look if
[ __ ] what you used to do I don't care
that you know you used to be the best
mother I don't care what are you doing
today you may not be that person now but
what are you still doing - trying to
excel in life and a lot of people now
are talking I hear so much talk I don't
hear a lot of work I hear like people
telling you what you should be doing how
you should be doing it how you should be
[ __ ] living and I look at them and
you're fat you're out of shape you look
like [ __ ] but you're telling a
[ __ ] how to live no man I won't
listen to you there's so many people
speak in this [ __ ] and that's what
bothered me a lot in the military
there's a lot of people talking [ __ ] I
don't see the real suffering behind it
behind what you're saying
everybody said man you talk with
someone's past because it's a real
[ __ ] place it sucks to get in the
morning something it was raining like
cats and dogs I don't get my shoes on go
run but guess what I got my [ __ ] on the
rain yeah got that mother bigquery's
like is the vision that's coming into my
mind is like is Jake LaMotta at the end
of raging ball when he's all fat and
he's staring himself in in his own lack
of accountability mirror right right
like drunk and talking about the good
old days right there are no good old
days man no no good old days you got ya
go back and use it for strength man but
it's where you at now I think the most
one of the most empowering
takeaways challenges that you pose in
the book
is the schedule that in thing man
because the biggest thing that I hear
and I know you must hear constantly
every single day is like can't I don't
have time man you don't know my life I
got this I got that I got this it's just
it's not gonna happen for me right which
you don't have is you haven't
prioritized your life correctly we all
have time we all have time what you've
done wrong is that you you didn't
prioritize yourself you didn't put eyes
that look [ __ ] I gotta get up
and win this war today against myself I
need you look better I need you feel
better to eat better I need to
prioritize time or I gotta run a hundred
miles on broken feet or you got do
whatever it is that's it that's it man
there's a lot of growth from that [ __ ] I
like this idea of you know doing taking
this inventory tool and applying it to
how you're spending your time throughout
the day you know I talk about this a lot
and you went into detail in this
challenge about look man if you if you
actually write down how you're spending
your time throughout the day over a
seven day period you're gonna mean it's
crazy cuz I thought I was being pretty
efficient with my time and I've done
this and it's just amazing how much time
is wasted that you're not even
consciously aware of unreal how much
time you waste during the day and most
of it is on these [ __ ] computers
phones you know instagramming back and
forth whatever the hook eCollege [ __ ]
nowadays tweeting and texting the [ __ ]
we waste so much time on our little
gadgets it's unreal every time but we
have no time if you really think you
have to take your day and write write
down this one day everything you do
write that down and you like my god I am
wasting so much time on frivolous
[ __ ] not funny I mean it will it
doesn't infuriate you it should because
there's so much time I can't get it in
look at your schedule just wasted seven
hours today on [ __ ] I mean you'll
have an hour a day to try to get
something in for yourself
I guarantee everybody can find an hour
then it becomes about willingness yeah
because no just there's harder they're
not willing to get up that early to you
know make those sacrifices required so
it's a function of how badly do you want
to change your life and what are you
willing to endure
to craft that life that you aspire to
have or do you just want to talk about
it yeah I mean it's [ __ ] miserable it
is miserable
I mean to get up every day or five days
a week whatever when it's snowing Shani
not not shiny not not comfortable and to
go into gym and workout when you don't
want to go to gym it is not fun well and
we're in a culture that that is driving
everybody towards this idea that
happiness is purchased through luxury
comfort and ease how true that could not
be you know more different from that
reality that if you want to find peace
with yourself self understanding self
knowledge self esteem all of these
things are going to be found only
through sacrifice getting uncomfortable
reevaluating what your normal is and and
putting yourself in situations that you
don't want to [ __ ] do yes and we want
it very fast if you don't see results in
the first two days or the first week I'm
done that's the mentality of most people
their struggle is too real we're not
patient we like in the world where you
can google the best restaurants around
me right now no one is patient and for
you to lose weight for you to stop drink
if you where the hell you're going
through it takes a lot of patience a lot
of time and a lot of pitfalls a lot of
plateaus you can hit so many [ __ ]
plateaus if you don't know how to get
around that plateau it's not gonna
happen fast mm-hmm yeah everybody wants
the hack yeah everybody must there is no
hack man
there's no hack what do you think is the
biggest stumbling block that most people
face with this kind of journey honestly
is they have the well with me mentality
it's too hard life isn't fair these
things in life are not easy for me you
you you look to your left you look to
your right and you start to judge
yourself off other people like if you're
a female she's skinny she doesn't work
out as hard as I do and everything
starts to corrupt your mind you start to
look around too much other people what
they're doing and that starts to corrupt
your own dialogue we are judging
ourselves against too many [ __ ]
people you have to judge yourself
against yourself and that's the one
thing I started learning this in the
race against me and rich roll this
racing is David Goggins and David
Goggins alone if once you can silence
all that [ __ ] all the outside
interference and things that are
attracting your mind to everything you
can then start to grow and realize and
I'm stressed out for no reason this is a
whole little race there's no little time
line and this time we run it I think
that so many people are so disconnected
from themselves they're operating on
autopilot they're reacting to their
environment that even when given the
opportunity to set a goal for themselves
they generally don't set the right goal
right because they don't know what the
[ __ ] they're doing because they don't
even know who they are fundamentally
that's the big thing man and that's why
it was important for me to finally
realize stop being all this fake people
I used to be stop being afraid there was
no growth until I cut myself down to
nothing to the person I really was the
real human being and once I found out
who I really was
that's when I started growing I was
trying to build on top of a lied
fucked-up foundation you can't build a
house in the [ __ ] up foundation so I
had to get down to the actual mineral
soil of who I was naturally you can
start real growth and what is the role
that suffering plays in that or the
willingness to suffer it starts to peel
all those layers away all those
artificial layers away if you're willing
to suffer and suffer and go back in the
grind that internal dialog you have with
yourself when you're in misery and
you're uncomfortable it's a real scary
unfiltered no lying dialogue between you
and yourself and people know exactly
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about when
you're in a bad spot in life and your
mind is saying all kind of [ __ ] that's
who you really are that's too real you
know Rocky Balboa moments going on up
there like hey you know it's around 14
that's come on we got this no
like [ __ ] this I'm out here man it's
crazy that's where the growth happens
when you're able to stay in that moment
and talk to yourself talking yourself
back into the suck of wherever you're
going through and you started stripping
those layers away but as you're
stripping those layers away you're
building calluses over top of [ __ ] in
your mind that's where the growth starts
to happen is when you have to force
yourself to stay in it
you can't you can't leave it that's why
ultras are such a great vehicle for self
exploration and that's why you see all
of these cultures over the millennia
that you talk about in your book who use
running as a means of self exploration
and a path to enlightenment because you
can't [ __ ] yourself when you're
getting it strips you down to who you
are and you could you are confronted
with the truth of yourself and your
reality and you're forced to wrestle
with that yes in a way where there's no
escape hatch you know like that first
hundred mile race I've talked about
several times where I lost all yeah all
every still the hardest physical thing
you've ever done right yes physically
mentally because like you just said I
was unprepared for that race no training
just recap it like zero training there
were 300 miles so that you could impress
Chris Kaufman it's too hard to get in
the bad water pretty much right and what
about impressing that guy fighting me
well you needed him to sign I need you
to sign off on it and it was like three
days later I'm in a hundred mile race no
train at all and when you do that it is
stupid but what it does if you're not
gonna quit it like you just talked about
it breaks you down to nothing
you are suffering so badly mentally and
physically that all of these demons are
coming up and you trying to find answers
and you're trying to find answers it it
was like live in 19 hours it's like five
years I put in two 19 hours of highs and
lows and pitfalls and and and seeing the
Sun come up and it was like my god I
live five years in 19 hours it was
unbelievable
it was unbelievable so do you find
yourself chasing that now with every
ultra challenge no because
once you realize what you get from ultra
which you get from life I can apply that
now just by sitting here with you
you know those tools now I don't need to
go out even though I still do it and go
out and Hammer the hammering part is
like you know it's like a purging of the
soul you go out there and hammer out
there you got to do that everyone's
wrong you got a hammer man you gotta ya
get after it but now I figured out so
many different ways and so many
different tools through all of the
journeys I've been through through just
growing up man just just be mature you
know just just being really mature and
now holding on hey you know really
really just letting all that [ __ ] go man
and it starting from scratch and let's
go let's go for how do you let it go I
don't think enough about people that
have let that have wronged me or
situations that have wronged me because
once you've ER once you've come to a
place where you are really happy with
who you are in life no one [ __ ] with
you anymore even though they're [ __ ]
with you it doesn't [ __ ] what it doesn't
[ __ ] with you you know like all these
eyes would be so hurt by everything in
the military and if someone did
Somerset's I'm like man I've overcome so
much [ __ ] there's not like I'm this in
the really good headspace right now my
headspace I own it a lot of people own
other people's headspace I owe my own
[ __ ] now what do you mean oh no like
that they're just all caught up and what
other people think about them and
running all these narratives and that's
right there they're more caught up in
what other people think about them then
how you feel about your own personal
self so a lot of people have their brain
in their mind on rent too whole bunch of
[ __ ] in world I am paying rent
on my own [ __ ] I finally put an ounce
downpayment on it and I'm making
payments everyday going day on my own
[ __ ] brain so you own you don't
[ __ ] control that [ __ ] anymore man I
got it so walk me through a day in the
life what's it look like right now well
I mean it's got to be crazy right now I
leave here and I fly out to Oregon and
I'll be an organ with Cameron Haynes
we'll be getting after for a few days a
lot more podcast lot more interviews but
every day
every morning I get up I still get my
run in every morning how do you
structure the training the training is
basically structured off of my schedule
so look at my schedule yeah that's okay
Jennifer would we have today we have
this at 7 o'clock in the morning Roger
that that means I gotta be up by 4
o'clock in the morning to run that's how
it works that's how all my [ __ ] works
so she lays out the schedule of events
to out you just you just set it two
hours earlier she says it could take an
hour to get to rich rolls let's say we
were at 7 o'clock today in the morning
it takes an hour to get to rich rolls
with no traffic ok that's that's
blocking an hour 15 for rich roll okay
we got that good morning tom I'm gonna
run 7 miles this morning I need 52:34
that Roger that put in [ __ ] shower shave
add that in so the schedule dictates but
I have all the [ __ ] back right so that
means getting up at 1:30 trust me
Roger that I've done that several times
yeah several how much sleep do you
usually get I like getting 7 to 8 hours
of sleep nowadays I can do that but
there's times where the schedule says
hey man you're getting three hours and
if that's the case right Merry Christmas
one of the things I felt that that maybe
Joe Rogan didn't quite grasp was why you
would go out and become this wildland
fire from this stage in your life right
yeah yeah yeah I'm looking at face like
what the [ __ ] that's once again going
back to the roots going back to Who I am
who how I became Who I am today and it
comes back from hard work it comes back
from having that very minimalistic
mindset and when you're out there man
and you're 43 and I've accomplished a
lot of [ __ ] you got there with some 20
year old kids and you're nobody again
being nobody there's a lot of power and
being nobody there's a lot of power from
going to scratch again and going back
out there picking up a Pulaski and just
digging fireline you're just another guy
on the line digging a fire line and no
one you know there's no
text message there's no my god David can
you sign my book
no I [ __ ] get your ass out there
it's like being in Army Ranger School I
do where all the titles are removed
removed that's executives man and I take
a I've always lived that lifestyle I
always talk about living day one week
one I started day one week one of buds
so many [ __ ] times and when you hear
that your heart is crumbling [ __ ] they
want week one again man I could go
through all that [ __ ] again like I said
it became my new norm and I found so
much growth in that day one week one
mentality but what I did wrong I tried
to put that mentality on a lot of people
and they don't want it yeah what do you
think people most misunderstand about
your story I'm not happy um what the
biggest thing is they say look at his
eyes
look at his eyes man have you seen his
eyes says he has demons in his eyes like
someone happy I'm like there's a lot of
projection you know and I see something
to see I think that the biggest thing is
I'm not happy I'm not I'm not fulfilled
you know all this [ __ ]
they're so missing the point man what
they see in me is a very focused driven
human being who found a buried [ __ ]
treasure within himself
now many people found it so the jury I'm
on is very different than most people as
well judge people I say that many times
I don't judge people I'm judged a lot
about how I look my eyes might not smile
all the time not laughing not joking and
that's the big I'm a funny [ __ ]
big-time but guess what
right now it's easy to be happy it's
easy to smile those are the good times -
good times
hmm those times don't need to be trained
you know how to train myself for good
times those times for most people don't
need be trained when I'm trying to give
you all is the misery of sometimes we go
through in life those are times we might
want to [ __ ] talk about we want to
skip forward to peace that's this
[ __ ] [ __ ] all this that's a skip all
this pain and suffering and misery of
real life let's
it's covered over nice big blanket and
that's fine piece no sorry it's not
possible
got go into that [ __ ] hellhole of
life that you have that [ __ ] you up and
fix it and that's what I'm here to do
you gotta go to war with yourself before
there's peace that's what I say in the
bush you say in the book you must go to
war yourself before you find peace so
I'm trying to give you tools on how to
do that and I'm not gonna sit and smile
and be happy about it it's a hard
journey it's a real journey it's a it's
a journey that's gonna take you way
outside of being comfortable you'd be
very very uncomfortable what we're
what's what we're here to do very I mean
I love that we'll see that I love that
story that you tell about you know
showing up at the pearly gates and
wanting to be evaluated based upon your
potential that's right I mean I believe
we're here to grow and progress and
evolve and if you're not committed to
that journey then I think you're missing
the beauty of life and that doesn't mean
it's easy cuz of [ __ ] ain't it is the
Warriors path truly how'd you percent
but if you don't acclimate to
challenging yourself and facing
obstacles and becoming better on a
consistent daily basis then what the
[ __ ] are you doing I was it and
sometimes you have to put the obstacle
in front of you that's why I went to be
right so now life's good and easy so you
have to create that's alright cuz I have
no office anymore man life is good so
I'm gonna go up to Montana or Wyoming or
what's right you go to let go I go to
Montana I said here's my obstacle so
what your life gets easy and everything
is great it's time to go online and go
with some obstacles to put like two
[ __ ] five you and when you look back
on your childhood and you think about
your dad do you find peace with that do
you find gratitude
100% man for me to start this journey
that had to start how to go back to
where it started from
and I I came from that man that man is a
part of me I had to accept that had
accept that a lot of my insecurities by
that man beaten
why that man beat my mom why that man
got in my head her bus said he had a
[ __ ] up life I had to study him and I
had to realize I had to find peace with
all that I had to realize that what he
did like he hated me mm-hmm
he hate himself and so once you start to
grow up and like I say take a different
vantage point I had to forgive that man
even though I didn't say sorry he never
said sorry we had our last conversation
at 22 years old and he died about four
or five years ago cause last time I
talked about 22 years old but he was
able to see you become successful from a
distance I think it hurt him I think it
hurt him because he saw me become a man
a man that he was very proud of and he'd
had much to do with it but once again I
didn't hate him for he was the fuel
beneath it all he was a lot of fuel man
but once but I will say this anger was
never my fuel a lot of people think that
I would think that would be maybe a big
misconception about it is it's easy to
look at you and that guy's that guy is
lit up and resentment even back in the
day so I gotta say I've never seen this
before I was actually telling my fiancee
this the other day people think anger
with my [ __ ] fuel just so yeah anger
can be a fuel anger got me to look into
things to become better I want to show
him but I'll tell you one thing when
you're suffering and your [ __ ] at the
wit's end and you want to [ __ ] quit
that anger is gone brother
well it's also not a sustainable fuel
lowers your mind is thinking about let's
get the [ __ ] out of here so I realized
this anger ain't [ __ ] I didn't think
about my dad beat me up I need my kids
coming [ __ ] I think about yeah [ __ ] I
thought my man this [ __ ] water is
cold as balls now get the [ __ ] out of
here so I realized anger was no fuel for
me it may have got me to say I want to
be somebody anger got me caught up in
some serious ego chips man yeah and on
the subject of sustainable fuel sources
motivations not your favorite motivation
is just this Goggins he's so motivation
motive
I'm so inspired and motivation has
killed a man is this killing liking all
these fires that happen here in
California man so so tragic what
happened out here but those fires start
by a little motivation and this if I'm
looking at mass like a like a little
spark starts these big fires it was so
crazy that's why I look at motivation
motivations just a spark but those
little sparks and something light comes
by real quick with some water that fires
doubt this out but if you come by and
that little fire no one touches it and
that little fire which is motivation
which is kindling and that kindling
grows off - like they call it when our
fuels - our fuels 10 our fuels $10,000
fuels you want that thing to ball over
and catch a nice big log let's go burn a
long time and that big loss starts
catching everything on fire this is your
soul so motivation a lot of times can be
[ __ ] just put some water on it puts
it out that motivation is to turn into
Drive passion obsession - what you want
to become and once they come obsession
or driven it's a [ __ ] Inferno so now
you got calling tons of fire fires and
call them for help for here calling for
help from there and they're not putting
that [ __ ] out don't they can take that
thing out it's gotta burn itself out but
obsession is self generated you can feel
another person to become obsessed though
that has to you know be something that
is cultivated deep deep inside yourself
deep and most people never experience
what it's like to be obsessed and I
think we put a negative label we oh yeah
on obsession oh yeah he's obsessed no
it's to me it's a it's a dead gone it's
a it's a compliment it's a compliment
mad to be and a lot of times it can [ __ ]
you up it can ruin your life you could
be upset but I'll tell you one thing if
you want to be great want to be bashed
[ __ ] ever at what you do you
could be misunderstood by everybody
because you're gonna be so [ __ ]
obsessed and so driven to get there
that's what it takes that's the trip
takes every second of your [ __ ] life
if anybody says balance yeah balance is
important for a lot of [ __ ] people it
is but if you want to [ __ ] go to that
edge
people do not like you don't understand
you question everything you [ __ ] do
you you've arrived when you are
misunderstood to the point where [ __ ]
people think you're psycho and you're
nuts and you're this and that why are
you in the [ __ ] gym at one o'clock in
the [ __ ] morning you've got through
doing an OP for [ __ ] 13 14 hours at
the Ranger school man
at the gym what's wrong you will never
understand what is wrong with me and
that's why I'm so [ __ ] glad you don't
cuz I'm in the right [ __ ] spot when
people don't understand you anymore
you're in that spot of obsession and
drive where people have quit the [ __ ] is
wrong with this guy I want to talk to
you man cuz you're not gonna get it I'm
not gonna get it
boom I want you to get it yeah don't
want you to get it yeah that's powerful
man alright well we got to land the ship
but I want to leave people with a couple
thoughts this is gonna go up on New
Year's Day it's the time of year where
everyone's thinking about what they want
their 2009 to look like 2019 to look
like they should have been thinking
about that a long time ago it's the way
it works for most people so let's let's
leave people let's let's get them you
know set on a good trajectory with a
couple things to think about and execute
on as I like lead into January how's
that man so I bought my set yeah that's
it man you have to change the dialogue
with in your head and one thing I
guarantee you there's some stat out
there about January 1 all that kindling
that you started or that motivation
usually burn out by about 10 to 12 days
later so I see how far you can take that
[ __ ] I see if you can get a [ __ ]
there's a challenge from Goggins do you
usually is 10 to 12 days man people
always coming man hey I want to work out
program I no longer give them anymore
cuz you go waste my [ __ ] time good I
know most people out there once that
[ __ ] one alarm clock goes off the
wrong time of the day I'm not going to
the gym right or they get the workout
program but then they're like hey they
hit you up again what kind of watch do I
need to guess right let's not use as
much just keep coming every
he goes by without anything going on
keep coming go to the store buy a pair
of shoes and Merry Christmas have fun
with that [ __ ]
call me after you lose some [ __ ]
weight running your ass in the dirt and
then we'll work on some other [ __ ] right
now get your base on there you go man
all right cool pleasure and an honor my
friend thank you so much for having me
on again rich I appreciate you missus
this is amazing
I cannot recommend this book more highly
can't hurt me get the audiobook get the
hardcover it's available right wherever
you buy books I'll put a link in the
show notes to it as well
this book will [ __ ] change your life
I promise you man and I'm no stranger to
these kind of narratives and I thought
like I said at the outset of this that I
knew the story I did not know the story
and I was profoundly impacted by it and
also just so great that that our mutual
friend Adam is part of this he's a man's
man he did a great job of capturing your
voice and I know this was you know a
long journey with the two of you guys
but it came out on top I went through a
lot of Ghost Rider's now I didn't come a
ghost right that's the wrong word Ghost
Writer server see that's why the so
called ghost right was hand in hand
right beside me doing the audiobook so
you know he sees a lot morning ghost
right he was a guy that captured a very
[ __ ] up life and he captured that [ __ ]
just right together we captured some
good [ __ ] so it's it's a good read yeah
it's gonna be awesome man all right dude
until next time Roger Roger that
[Music]
you